Now let's look at the code for getting an entity
out of the datastore. Since you know the key for a
profile entity, as Mark has explained, you can use the
key to easily yank the, the entity out of the datastore.
You've already learned how to save entities and how to
view them in the admin console. The obvious next step is
to extend the conference center application to get the profile entities
back out of the datastore. With objectify, you use the ofy.load
function to load an entity. You can get an
entity by key or you can query for entities
that match search criteria. You'll be learning how to
retrieve entities by key first. Then in the next lesson
you'll learn how to query for entities that satisfy
certain criteria. Let's take a look at the code
to get an entity out of the data store.
Ofy gets the objectify service. Load, loads the entity. Key,
is the key of the entity to load. And
now means, do it now, don't wait, in other words,
do it synchronously. That's all well and good, but
how do you get the key? You need to know
the unique ID that was used to generate the
key. Remember how you used the [UNKNOWN] annotation to identify
user ID as the ID when creating a profile entity.
The ID is used to generate the key. The ID
isn't the key by itself but its essential to
generating the key. So, for any user who's logged in,
your app can retrieve the user ID, which means you
can generate the key and consequently get the profile entity
directly from the datastore. As you've already learned, the user
is parsed in the call to the end points method
and you can simply get the user ID like this,
getUserId. To get a key, you call the create method
on the key class and you need to specify the
kind of entity that you want to retrieve. Here entity's actually
a variable, so let's say we were creating a key
for recipe, this would be recipe.class. Then you need to pass
the ID that was used to generate the key, in
this case we're using user ID. So now we know the
ID and we know the key, we can get the entity
from the data store using the key. Now it's your turn
to work on your conference central app.
You need to complete the getProfile method by
filling in the TODO to load and return
the profile entity. You'll need to get the
userID, you'll need to create the key, and you get the profile, and then you
return the profile. When you've implemented getProfile, you
can try it out in the APIs Explorer